[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo und willkommen zu unserem heutigen
Fall ich bin Mirko Kasimir und ich bin
Toni Heyer hallo zusammen unsere heutige
Geschichte ist in ihren Ausmaßen so
monströs dass sie Justizgeschichte in
Deutschland geschrieben hat das sieht
man auch an unseren Unterlagen ja das
Landgericht Oldenburg wird auf das 514
Dokumente ausgewertet wurden
hauptsächlich Gutachten es wurden im
Verfahren 32 Zeugen gehört am 6 juni
2019 wurde der eingeklagte durch die
spurgerichtskammer wegen Mordes in 85
Fällen schuldig gesprochen und in 15
Fällen freigesprochen und hier sind die
Bezeichnungen der Mordwerkzeuge Kalium
kiloid mal so talex
aufgedeckt wurde nicht nur die größte
Mordserie der Bundesrepublik vor Gericht
wurde auch klar dass viele Leute sich
sehr
ignorant einstellen mussten um sie
überhaupt möglich zu machen und wir
fangen jetzt mal mit dem man an der im
Mittelpunkt dieses unfassbaren
Geschehens steht
Nils Högel wird am 30 dezember 1976 im
niedersächsischen Wilhelmshaven geboren
seine Mutter arbeitet als Gehilfin bei
einem Rechtsanwalt sein Vater und seine
Oma in der Krankenpflege als Kind
spielte gern Fußball mit 21 Jahren
schließt er am Klinikum Wilhelmshaven
seine Krankenpflegeausbildung ab das
damals noch Sankt Villa hat Hospital
heißt er wird übernommen zwei Jahre
später
1999 wechselt Vögel im Juni auf die
herzchirurgische Intensivstation am
Klinikum Oldenburg Station 211 bis
hierhin sind keine Ungereimtheiten
bekannt aber in Oldenburg fällt auf das
Vögel sich bei Reanimationen in den
Vordergrund drängt und dabei bleibt es
erstmal zwei Jahre später diskutieren
Ärzte und Pfleger Bergstation bei einer
Krisensitzung warum es in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten so viele
Wiederbelebungen und Todesfälle auf der
herzintensivstation gab auch Högel nimmt
an dieser Besprechung Teil nach dem
Treffen meldet er sich krank für drei
Wochen in dieser Zeit gibt es nur halb
so viele Todesfälle wie sonst jetzt
kommen wir zu einem Punkt in diesem Fall
der einen fassungslos macht dabei haben
wir jetzt eigentlich gerade erst
angefangen also der Chefarzt der
Herzchirurgie hat in Bezug auf Vögel ein
ungutes Gefühl und lässt ihn in die
Anästhesie versetzen und auch da fällt
den Kollegen bald auf das Hügel oft in
der Nähe ist wenn es um Leben und Tod
geht aber anstatt Ermittlungen
anzustoßen vergrault die Klinik den Mann
lieber besser noch sie will ihn
unauffällig loswerden
im September 2002 wird Hügel von der
Klinikleitung zur Kündigung gedrängt
zuvor waren mehrere Patienten unter
seiner Obhut in Lebensgefahr geraten was
ich so crazy daran finde es ist ja
irgendwie klar dass er zumindest
irgendwie grob was damit zu tun haben
muss also ich meine es gibt diese
Krisensitzung er ist krank ist sterben
weniger Leute er wird versetzt auf
einmal passieren dort mehrere
Zwischenfälle als normal
und da sitzen jetzt Leute die schon
ungutes Gefühl haben und eine Mordserie
aufdecken bzw stoppen könnten was machen
die die machen die Augen zu ja das hat
ja viel später auch noch ein Nachspiel
Toni aber erstmal kommt es leider noch
schlimmer im Herbst desselben Jahres
verlässt Vögel das Klinikum Oldenburg
mit einem Arbeitszeugnis in dem steht er
habe umsichtig gewissenhaft und
selbstständig gearbeitet und in
kritischen Situationen überlegt und
sachlich richtig gehandelt gelobt wird
außerdem seine Einsatzbereitschaft und
sein kooperatives Verhalten okay ich sag
jetzt nichts ich atme jetzt einmal
tief durch
okay
högelwechselt mit diesem Bomben Zeugnis
nach Delmenhorst da fängt der am 15
dezember 2002 an und zwar auf der
Intensivstation super von März bis Juni
2003 verdoppelt sich die Todesrate dort
von etwa durchschnittlich 200 auf 411
gleichzeitig wird das Mittel die lorith
mal viel häufiger gespritzt als sonst es
wird zur Behandlung von
Herzrhythmusstörungen eingesetzt aber
diese Zahlen werden erst später erhoben
über Hügel heißt es später am Anfang
habe er alle von sich überzeugt dann
seien die Kollegen misstrauisch geworden
aber es braucht noch eine Zuspitzung bis
der Pfleger endlich aufliegt 22 juni
2005 Högel hat Dienst auf der
Intensivstation in Delmenhorst
er versorgt in einem der Zimmer den
63-Jährigen Patienten weiter m eine
Schwester kommt dazu und ertappt Hügel
auf frischer Tat der hat 40 ml kiloid
mal gespritzt und eine Pumpe mit einem
lebenswichtigen Medikament abgeschaltet
sie meldet den Vorfall der
Stationsleitung der Patient überlebt und
jetzt wird es wieder unbegreiflich denn
die Chefs sagen sich
der hat ja nur noch eine Spätschicht und
dann Urlaub vertragen wir dieses
unangenehme Thema mal und später wird
klar sogar noch in dieser letzten
Schicht hat Vögel jemanden umgebracht ja
und dieses hinauszögern ist wirklich
unverzeihlich aber trotzdem kommt der
Stein jetzt endlich ins Rollen die
Polizei wird eingeschaltet und mehrere
Mitarbeiter des Klinikums äußern den
Verdacht das Vögel für zahlreiche
Todesfälle verantwortlich sein könnte
die Polizei ermittelt daraufhin
umfangreich und untersucht alle
Todesfälle im Zeitraum von 2003 bis 2005
in der Ärztezeitung findet sich dazu der
Name von Kurt Schwender der damals
Oberarzt im Klinikum Delmenhorst ist und
ich stelle mir ist echt ziemlich traurig
vor wie er sich dabei gefühlt haben muss
wegen der Ermittlungen durchforstet der
Ende 2005 die gesamten Unterlagen
vielleicht sitzt er weit nach Feierabend
allein im sonst dunklen Bürotrakt und
ihm wird klar dass Nils Vögel wohl bis
zu 100 Menschen in seinem Krankenhaus
getötet hat gemessen daran kommt der
erstaunlich gut davon es kommt also zu
einem ersten Prozess gegen den Mann der
jetzt als todespfleger bekannt wird
verurteilt wird er wegen versuchten
Totschlags zu fünf Jahren Haft und einem
fünfjährigen Berufsverbot also da ging
es um den Fall als die Schwester ihn auf
dem Zimmer erwischt hatte als er gerade
diese Maschine ausgestellt hatte und das
falsche Medikament Spritzen wollte
auf Betreiben der Nebenklage hebt der
Bundesgerichtshof das Urteil aber auf in
einem zweiten Anlauf lautet es
siebeneinhalb Jahre Haft und
lebenslanges Berufsverbot ja jetzt ist
der Mann endlich hinter Gittern aber das
ganze bleibt kein Ruhmesblatt für die
Justiz wie man im Weser Kurier gut
nachlesen kann meldet sich nach dem
Urteil eine Katrin Lohmann bei der
Polizei ihre Mutter Brigitte war 2003
auf der Intensivstation in Delmenhorst
unter höchst fraglichen Umständen
gestorben die Polizei reagiert
vorbildlich und findet heraus dass Hügel
in der fraglichen Nacht wirklich Dienst
hatte aber die Staatsanwaltschaft
wiegelt ab der Mann sei doch schon
verurteilt und eine extremierung der
Mutter zu teuer zum Glück lässt Katrin
Lohmann nicht locker und als ihre Mutter
endlich noch mal von der Gerichtsmedizin
untersucht wird steht fest
die Frau wurde mit einer Überdosis
gelorith mal getötet mit ihrer
Hartnäckigkeit ermöglicht Lohmann einen
weiteren Prozess gegen Hügel der Fall
wird zu einem Debakel für die Justiz und
die Krankenhäuser in denen Högel
gearbeitet hat immer wieder muss die
Staatsanwaltschaft die Ermittlungen
erweitern Akten durch Forsten
leichenexformieren lassen
2015 gibt es eine große Pressekonferenz
bei dem man sich wortreich entschuldigt
tatsächlich wird sogar ein früherer
Staatsanwalt angeklagt weil er die
Ermittlungen verschleppt haben soll
Vorwurf Strafvereitelung im Amt das
zuständige Gericht lehnt einen Prozess
aber ab es kommt nie zum Prozess dafür
gibt es 2015 ein weiteres Urteil gegen
den todespfleger lebenslange Haft wegen
zweifachen Mordes zweifachen
Mordversuchs sowie gefährliche
Körperverletzung im Klinikum Delmenhorst
schön und gut aber was ist mit hügelzeit
im Klinikum Oldenburg der Toni das ist
eine fast endlose Geschichte
die Kurzfassung lautet wie folgt es
werden noch mal 200 Fälle aufgerollt und
insgesamt 134 Tote auf 67 verschiedenen
Friedhöfen exhumiert und dann folgt der
große Prozess mit dem wir vorhin diesen
Podcast begonnen haben 6 juni 2019 Högl
wird in 85 Fällen schuldig gesprochen
und zum zweiten Mal zu einer lebenslang
Freiheitsstrafe verurteilt Bild schreibt
damals auf diesen Tag haben viele
Angehörige der getöteten Menschen
gewartet und zitiert den Richter
Sebastian Bührmann
sie sind eine narzisstische
Persönlichkeit sie haben uns häufig
nicht die Wahrheit gesagt sie waren
damals oft abgeklärt und cool sie hatten
schon etliche Menschen in Not gebracht
hatten schon 50 60 getötet und haben
weitergemacht die erste Tötung von der
wir wissen haben sie am 22 dezember 2002
in Delmenhorst begangen eine Woche nach
ihrem Dienst beginnt dort es ist alles
unfassbar ja unfassbar ist das alles
bleibt aber das unbegreiflichste warum
hat Högel all diese Menschen getötet
diese Frage findet sich in vielen
Berichten und Protokollen wieder und ich
sag mal was mir aufgefallen ist das
Töten hat in ihm nach eigenen Aussagen
ein Hochgefühl ausgelöst dass er immer
wieder gesucht fast schon gejagt hat und
er ist wohl über die Jahre auch in
Süchte abgerutscht ja das ist mir auch
aufgefallen in den Berichten über das
2019er Urteil denn da stand dass er
immer mehr trank und auch Schmerzmittel
Einnahmen ja vermutlich und mit dem
einen noch klar zu kommen krassesten
finde ich dass es hauptsächlich das
Motiv gab anzugeben so ein tafer Typ und
cooler Pfleger zu sein das war im ganz
wichtig also Hügel spritzte Herzmittel
in Überdosis und zeigte den Kollegen
dann wie toll er wiederbeleben und
Menschen retten kann so eine Art
Selbstwert Booster
das ist wirklich krank ein Gutachter
nannte das ganze mal narzisstisch die
sozial und zwanghaft ja das würde ich
unterschreiben jetzt gibt es aber nur
noch ein Kapitel und zwar wie konnte die
Leitung in Oldenburg so fahrlässig sein
Vögel einfach vorzuschicken und dann
auch noch mit so einem bombastisch guten
Zeugnis das führte tatsächlich zu einem
weiteren Prozess der noch nicht lange
her ist ich lese aus der Bild vom
13.10.2022 vor Bremen den Prozess gegen
sieben frühere Vorgesetzte des
patientenmörders Nils Högel hat das
Landgericht Oldenburg alle Angeklagten
freigesprochen damit folgte das Gericht
den Forderungen von Staatsanwaltschaft
und Verteidigung okay Mirko die sind
jetzt frei gesprochen aber ich meine es
gab doch auf Seiten der Leitung des
Klinikums schon immer wage Vermutungen
ja das stimmt Toni die Staatsanwältin
Gesa weiß hatte zum Beispiel in ihrem
schlussplädoy hier gesagt das ist zwar
Auffälligkeiten und die Vermutungen
gegeben hätte jedoch sei kein Vorsatz zu
erkennen gewesen okay also können wir
mal kurz zusammenfassen die haben eine
riesige Scheiße gebaut und die hätten
mit Sicherheit früher einschreiten
müssen und auch können haben sie aber
nicht gemacht vielleicht auch ich kann
mir gut vorstellen man möchte nicht
wahrhaben dass jemand aus dem eigenen
Team sowas furchtbares macht dass das so
eine Art Verdrängung war aber klar das
schützt irgendwie auch nicht vor der
Mitschuld und ich meine selbst wenn sie
nicht verurteilt sind mit diesem Wissen
müssen sie weiterleben dass sie er
hätten eingreifen können ja das hat man
offensichtlich verdrängt aber immerhin
hat man in den Krankenhäusern versucht
aus diesem Fall zu lernen Oldenburg und
Delmenhorst haben als erste Kliniken in
Deutschland die qualifizierte
Leichenschau eingeführt das bedeutet
dass immer ein zweiter Rechtsmediziner
bei einer Leichenschau dabei sein muss
das ist ja immerhin etwas was sie daraus
gelernt haben und hoff auch lieber
einmal zu viel den Mund aufmachen als
einmal zu wenig und das finde ich das
krasseste an diesem ganzen Fall dass Sie
gesagt haben er hat noch eine
Nachtschicht und dann Urlaub wir
vertagen das mal nicht vertragen bitte
sofort wenn irgendwas komisch ist sofort
eingreifen aber ich glaube das ist so
egal in welchem Beruf so ich bin sehr
froh dass solche Fälle hatten wir ja
auch neulich schon mal
trotz allem auch wenn man öfter davon
hört die absolute Ausnahme sind ja ich
glaube da gibt es auch erstmal so eine
innere Sperre man möchte es ja nicht den
eigenen Kollegen unterstellen auf jeden
Fall eine sehr sehr schreckliche Sache
dazu beigetragen hat sicherlich auch
dass man ihn aus dem einen Krankenhaus
mit diesem Arbeitszeugnis mehr oder
minder
weggelobt hat ja also man wollte ihn
natürlich loswerden und hat das gedacht
man macht das indem man ihm ein super
tolles Arbeitszeugnis ausstellt was beim
Dienstantritt bei der nächsten
Arbeitsstelle
zum offensichtlich perfekten Pfleger
gemacht hat ja das ist halt eigentlich
das Fatale so nach dem Motto wir
schieben jetzt mal das unangenehme weg
von uns ähm ganz schnell gutes Zeugnis
dann hat irgendjemand anders in einer
Backe und es ist nicht mehr unser
Problem
ja sowieso nicht ne weil sobald Leute
Menschen so ein bisschen Herr überleben
und Tod sein können
du kannst ja keine charakterprüfung
machen nee und ich meine es wird immer
es wird immer schwarze Schafe geben es
gibt immer schlechte Menschen auch wenn
Gott sei Dank die Mehrheit der
Menschheit im Herzen gut ist das wird
halt immer solche Leute geben die auch
ihre Position missbrauchen ausnutzen
das ist richtig auf jeden Fall schön
dass ihr heute wieder mit dabei wart
[Musik]
ein Fall haben wir erzählt mit einer
Handreichung des Landgerichts Oldenburg
Berichten aus der Bild- und BILD am
SONNTAG einer Chronik auf nDR.de sowie
der Nordwest-Zeitung und dem Ärzteblatt
Skript Stefan Netzeband Aufnahme und
schnitt Toni Heyer Postproduktion durch
Wake world München bis zum nächsten mal
euer Wirkung und eure Toni